a quick word about the outdoors it's
home to lakes trees and the candy witch
who lures children to their doom it's
great specifically though i want to talk
about one way to conserve the precious
nature that the outdoors contains and
that is duck stamps if you've never
heard of them i'll let this charmingly
stilted 1990s video explain it to you
the majority of stamps are sold to
waterfowl hunters who by law must have a
federal duck stamp in their possession
while hunting increasingly others young
and old are voluntarily buying federal
duck stamps as an effective direct way
to help conserve our nation's waterfowl
and other wildlife now i know that looks
sweet but to be fair what you didn't see
there is the screaming that happened as
soon as though two kids got home what
are these duck stamps i sent you to the
store for medicine listen to me your
sister is about to die because he keeps
spending all of her insulin money on
bird stickers
but it is true every year the federal
government issues a duck stamp which
isn't a postage stamp but it's
effectively a kind of permit for hunters
they currently cost 25 and they've
actually been a huge success story for
conservation with 98 cents of every
dollar that they make going to
protecting wetlands since 1934 the
stamps have raised more than a billion
dollars to protect over six million
acres of wetlands habitat and that is
partly because non-hunters like to
collect these duck stamps too and you
can see why there have been some
beauties in the past like this 1960s
stamp featuring a family of redhead
ducks this 1981 showcasing majestic snow
goose and this mottled duck from the
2000s who is absolutely ripped check out
the definition on that back quick
question does this stamp come with mushu
pancakes because that duck is
shredded
but the best thing about the duck stamp
is how each years is chosen because it's
an annual nationwide art competition and
the judging of it is no joke
the judges independently vote on each
entry they consider not only the visual
impact of the art and how it might look
as a stamp but also whether it is
anatomically accurate yeah it's true
ducks must not only be beautiful but
also anatomically accurate and
especially fun requirement given that
you're painting an animal that has as we
have mentioned on this show before a
long corkscrew-shaped penis it is a fact
that drove us to create this image of
donald duck that as our taping disney
has not yet sued us over and once you
start looking into the duck stamp
contest it is not long before you find
some drama there are big names like the
hotman brothers an actual duck dynasty
who going into this year's competition
had collectively won it 13 times they
truly are the duck goats and there's
also been a heated rivalry between one
of the regular traditional duck artists
tim taylor and his more avant-garde
rival rob mcbroom who tim taylor has no
time for rob mcbroom is a guy who enters
the duck stamp every year
and every year he violates the rules he
breaks
every role of the contest
and he's really just an intention seeker
he's found this contest that people take
very seriously
and the contestants work really hard on
their entries and he mocks it he does
paintings that mock it yeah to be fair
he does kind of do that he submitted
paintings to federal and state contests
that clearly go against the desired
aesthetic like this one of two
cartoonish ducks and whatever the
this is
also rob mcgroom is very much aware of
tim taylor's criticism and trolled him
for years even taking previous taylor
paintings and parodying them
this is about as close as you can get to
tim's original without actually knowing
the size
and it's completely built from scratch
this is the piece of work that rob
mcbroom took off of the internet to
abstract the little bits i've learned
about him
i'm like okay he obviously hates
barack obama and he hates communism
so i decided to load it up with imagery
with that
here's barack obama's birth certificate
that he released
here's the eye of the duck which is the
communist symbol
there's other things in here like he was
holding a baby at a christening and then
i put lennon's head on top of me
wow
that is betty
honestly if i were tim i might back off
at this point because if this man made a
communist duck out of your personal
photographs just think what else he's
capable of here's another one tim the
feathers are made out of bank statements
i've fished out of your trash and the
beak is from a photo of you i took while
you were sleeping but by all means keep
talking
the point here is the duck stamp
competition is intense last year there
were some incredible entries like this
one of a duck somehow tripping in
mid-air and this one which i would argue
is actually a dog stamp a dog on his way
to a leather bar while a duck happened
to be passing i'm not saying that as a
criticism i'm just saying that is what
it is but the overall winner was this
objectively wonderful very anatomically
accurate painting of a lesser scalp
drake by artist richard clifton and
hiding the duck's coily dick underwater
was a very smart move there richie you
can't see it but you know it's down
there swirling away
quick fun side note that duck call in
the corner is only there because under
the trump administration there was
suddenly a rule that all entries had to
feature hunting imagery which many
people understandably did not really
like thankfully that rule will be gone
next year which is good because
potentially driving people away from the
duck stamp is a really terrible idea
stamp sales are already down and as you
now know that means less money for
conservation what clearly needs to
happen is for more people to be driven
to collecting these things and for that
to work you really need this year's
entry to be an absolute doozy
and that is where we come in because the
fact is anyone can enter this contest
and i'm happy to announce that this year
this anyone did
we commissioned
we commissioned a painter to create this
gorgeous oil painting of a blue winged
teal
flying
in the nintendo game duck hunt meeting
their ridiculous hunting requirements
this is a real beautifully detailed
painting that took months of work but
i'm sorry to say it was actually
disqualified because of and i quote the
rule against having any numbers or
lettering on the entry which is a truly
ridiculous requirement it's like if they
said no duck stamp is allowed to feature
cans of spaghettios or paul sorvino what
happened in past contests that prompted
that regulation
so so that is the bad news the good news
is we actually had a second entry
specifically this painting of ducks
judging the duck stamp art contest
unfortunately
we fell victim to the same
number rule and this was disqualified
too so you can probably imagine just how
relieved we were to suddenly remember
that we'd actually entered three other
paintings as well all of which i'm happy
to say did qualify for this weekend's
contest so let's take a look at them
first there is this one of a redhead
duck hunting a hunter hunting another
duck behold the ominous
quietly maniacal look in that duck's
eyes he's about to pull the trigger it's
a haunting yet triumphant image so let's
see if the duck stamp judges liked it
please vote
it's out
are you kidding me
not one of you judges voted for that
ridiculous simply ridiculous all five of
you should be ashamed of yourselves but
you know what you know what it's fine
because remember we still had two others
next up was this entry duck with a pearl
earring which i would argue
is exquisite it makes the original
vermeer look like a complete pile of
that girl doesn't even have any
feathers or a beak for that matter what
a waste of paint so surely
surely the judges loved this one
please vote
out
oh come on
these judges are clowns
they don't know about art they
don't know about ducks and they
certainly don't know about duck art
and look
i'm not alone in being shocked by this
the people watching the contests live
stream were very into this entry writing
gorgeous perfect stunning
yes and
i want that on my wall and of course
they do what cultured duck art lover
would not want that so at this point i
admit we were getting pretty nervous
luckily our final painting was
guaranteed to blow everyone away because
it is this masterpiece depicting a giant
duck brokering piece between long-time
duck art rivals tim taylor and rob
mcbroom no one in their right mind would
not put this through at least to the
second round right so judges it's over
to you
please vote
it's out
yourself straight to hell
i'm sorry the federal duck stamp contest
just lost all of its integrity although
i do admit the judges were not actually
the only ones who did not care for that
entry tim taylor himself actually
replied to the painting in the chat with
i don't know why anyone painted that
really tim
you don't i know why someone would pack
that it's because one we paid them two
and two it's awesome that's why
so sadly none of our entries made it
past the first round of voting and
eventually the prize went to this entry
now for the winner of the 2022-23 duck
stamp contest
with the painting of a redhead
mr jim haltman from chesca minnesota
this is six
wins
get the out you know what you know
what
i have to say that's a beautiful duck
painting i do kind of get why the hotman
brothers keep winning this contest that
said personally i do still prefer our
duck hunt one it's funnier and better
and would have been a cooler stamp but
look i am obviously disappointed that we
not only did not win the duck stamp art
contest this year we didn't even get a
single vote from any judge although i do
think that says more about them than it
does about our paintings because if any
of us had won they could have helped
raise a bunch of money for a very good
cause and the good news is they actually
still can please come with me
because
i'm proud to say that we've decided to
auction off each of these absolute
masterpieces with a hundred percent of
the proceeds going to the federal duck
stamp program and you know what that
means that means that you yes you have
the chance to hang any of these
originals in your home you could get rid
of your stupid family portraits and
replace it with something much much
better all you have to do is go to
bestduckingstamps.com
and bid on whichever piece speaks to you
the most you can bid until friday at 10
30 p.m and i'm now proud to say ladies
and gentlemen
the bidding starts now
that is our show thank you so much for
watching we'll see you next week good
night
um
[Applause]
[Music]
you